president Trump meets with Vladimir
Putin Anastasio Cortez Ortega says
something really really dumb and Sasha
Baron Cohen is back at it I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
I always screw up that lady's name and I
don't know why maybe this is really long
well we'll talk about her in a little
bit first I want to say thanks to our
sponsors over at bull and branch so if
you are not sleeping as well as you
ought that is because your sheets are
not as good as they ought to be and that
is where bull and branch comes in
everything bull and branch makes from
their bedding to their blankets made
from pure 100% organic cotton
it means they start out super soft they
get even softer over time you can buy
directly from them so you are
essentially paying wholesale prices
luxury sheets can cost up to a thousand
bucks in the store bull and brand sheets
are only a couple of hundred bucks I
sleep on Bolin branch eats they are
amazing and I love them that's why we
have thrown out all of our other sheets
and we only have Boleyn branch in the
house even three u.s. presidents sleep
on bull and branch eats shipping is free
you can try them for 30 nights if you
don't love them send them back for a
refund you're not gonna want to send
them back there's no risk no reason not
to give them a try to get you started
right now my listeners get 50 bucks off
your first set of sheets at bull and
branch calm promo code Ben that's bull
and branch calm promo code Ben again you
get $50 off when you use that promo code
Ben it's bol el and branch calm promo
code Ben all of their bedding is
ridiculously awesome their sheets are
particularly great and if you're looking
for something that is breathable and yet
soft then bull and branch is for you
beau and branch calm promo code Ben get
that $50 off your first set of sheets
also a reminder our next episode of the
conversation is here tomorrow Tuesday
July 17 5:30 p.m. Eastern 2:30 p.m.
Pacific all of your questions will be
answered by our own Andrew Clavin with
our host Alicia Krause our live Q&A will
be available on YouTube and Facebook for
everyone to watch only subscribers can
ask drew questions over at daily
wire.com so check out the pin comments
on this video for all the information
once again subscribe ask through live
questions tomorrow Tuesday July 17th
5:30 p.m. Eastern 2:30 p.m. Pacific join
the conversation ask drew about how he
does his hair in the morning okay so
president Trump has met now with
Vladimir Putin they met for about two
hours this morning and they spent a lot
of the time talking about various issues
specifically about Russian election
meddling now Putin came out afterward
and he said we talk about election
meddling but I tell him I will do it and
then president Trump comes out and he
says we talked about it and we talked
about it very lengthily and that was
pretty much the only thing we found out
from this meeting and they spent
enormous amounts of time talking
specifically about the election meddling
and Putin says we do not do least and
president Trump said well I don't know
whether they did or not but
we talked about a lot and everybody went
crazy over it now if all of that sounds
a little bit anticlimactic to you it's
because it is anti-climatic and people
are taking away from it what they want
to take away from it so on the Left what
they're taking away from this Trump
Putin summit is that Trump got job the
Trump got played the Trump basically
made all sorts of concessions to the
Russians we won't find out about until
later but at least in terms of his
language who's very sick of Fanta and in
terms of his language he was very sick
of Fanta because President Trump has
been consistently sycophantic with
regard to Vladimir Putin for at least
three years now it is not true that his
policy has been sycophantic and this is
where the left seems to go wrong they
seem to immediately connect everything
from says with everything Trump does but
there is a massive problem with doing
that inside this administration
President Trump very often acts like a
free agent inside his own administration
he goes out and he says stuff and then
the people who do his policy behind
closed doors they do a policy that looks
nothing like what he said we've seen
this over and over and over we've seen
President Trump say while he was a
candidate that he wanted health care for
all and then as soon as he got into
place then all of a sudden his people
were pushing a repeal of Obamacare when
President Trump was saying during the
campaign he wanted to raise taxes on the
rich and then he passed a bill that did
not raise taxes on the rich at lower
taxes on the rich among others well that
was another example of the disconnect
Russia is the biggest disconnect because
President Trump says very nice things
about Vladimir Putin on a regular basis
and then when it comes to policy the US
will bomb Syrian air bases with Russian
planes there the US will kill Russian
mercenaries in Syria the US will arm the
Ukrainians with deadly weaponry in a way
that Obama never would have so this
massive disconnect is confusing a lot of
people but it does show that inside the
United States inside his own
administration inside his own
administration there are a lot of people
who are not taking his verbiage
seriously and I don't think Vladimir
Putin is taking his verbiage seriously
either there seems to be a concept out
there that Vladimir Putin is gonna look
at Trump and think wow that guy's a
softy his softy I picked golf in
Lithuania now that's not going to happen
because Putin does not take his words
all that seriously it is also worth
noting then the first year and a half of
their administration's Bush and Obama
were not much better when it came to
signalling softness with the Russians
you remember george w bush got together
with vladimir putin after 9/11 and he
said he looked into putin's soul and he
saw something magical there yeah what he
saw was putin looking at taking over
Georgia and then Barack Obama in 2012
said he wanted to grant flexibility to
the Russians and then he proceeded to
grant the
Crimea so all of this talk about Trump
is you know universally and and
strangely and and in weird fashion
pro-russian that mayor a car that may
apply to his rhetoric but it certainly
doesn't apply to his policy now when it
comes to his rhetoric his rhetoric does
kind of suck right so Trump has jumped
into this this meeting with Putin and he
suggests that the United States is
responsible for the poor state of
us-russia relations he tweeted out this
morning the us-russia relations have
never been worse he tweeted out a
relationship with Russia has never been
worse thanks to many years of u.s.
foolishness and stupidity and now the
rigged witch-hunt
yeah well that's not great because none
of that is true the reason that our
relationship with Russia sucks is
because Vladimir Putin is a thug in a
dictator who's attempted to expand his
sphere of influence broadly across the
region everywhere from Iran to
Kazakhstan and you've seen President
Putin he's him him seize power and keep
himself in power for nearly 20 years
over in Russia at this point it's not
because of u.s. foolishness and
stupidity alone it's because of Vladimir
Putin being Vladimir Putin and it's not
because of the rigged witch hunts okay
it's not because the the Muller
investigation is going after Trump now
in a second I'm going to talk about how
this plays in and why this makes people
think that Trump is in the Russians
pocket I don't think that's what's
happening here and we'll explain why the
Moller investigation plays into Trump's
picture of Russia in just a second but
suffice it to say that that comment is
really dumb and it leaves people
believing that Trump is much more Pro
Russia in his policy than he actually is
and then Reuters asked Trump about that
tweet and Trump said we've all been
foolish we're all the blame we have a
chance to do some great things and he
stopped it he highlighted stopping
nuclear proliferation
he said the probe is a disaster for our
country there was no collusion he said I
think that we're all to blame on all of
this it's it's the to show how bad the
suite was the ministry from Foreign
Affairs from Russia tweeted out agreeing
with it
my Russian tweeted out we agree we agree
so Trump says it's our fault and Russia
says we agree now let's be clear if
Barack Obama had said this I'd be all
over him maybe all over him and so it'd
behoove me not to be a hypocrite
president Trump should not say such
things because this is gross okay when
the President of the United States
blames the United States for our
conflicts with Russia that is just silly
in every available sense but I think
what's really going on here
something else so what's really going on
here the President of the United States
really really really does not like this
Russian collusion investigation and he
thinks that because the Russian
collusion investigation is a witch-hunt
against him it is also a witch-hunt
against Russia these are not the same
thing these are not the same thing and
this is where we go back to late last
week late on Friday last week rod
Rosenstein Deputy Attorney General he
announced there'd be 12 indictments
coming down of Russian citizens who'd
been responsible for working to hack
into the DCCC and the DNC and to the
Hillary Clinton campaign so rod
Rosenstein announced last week that
we're not Republicans we're not
Democrats this is just about going after
people who violate the law we confront
foreign interference in American
elections it's important for us to avoid
thinking politically as Republicans or
Democrats and instead to think as
Americans and this is exactly right okay
rod Rosenstein for all the problems that
you have with Rob Rosenstein rod Rosen
seen what he says here is exactly
correct I don't think that Russia
colluded with the Trump campaign to skew
the election away from Hillary Clinton I
do think that Russian sources attempted
to hack into the election the the the
DCCC and the DNC they attempt to they
attempted to screw with the election
itself and so when Rosenstein says we
should worry about the law the the law
breaking we shouldn't worry so much
about how it affects either of the
parties he's exactly right about this
and as we discussed last week the
indictment itself the indictments are
pretty telling there are a few things to
know about that right it is pretty clear
from these indictments the GRU agents
that would be the new fangled KGB 12 GRU
officers knowingly and intentionally
conspired with each other and with
persons known and unknowns hacked the
emails of the Clinton campaign the DCCC
and the DNC around April 2016 the
conspirators began planning how to
release Hillary Clinton's emails around
June they began releasing that material
via DC leaks and gucci fir 2.0 and they
Spearfish John Podesta as well as other
top Clinton campaign officials they got
a lot of material they also released
some Republican material from 2015 the
hackers created Lucifer 2.0 Roger stone
who was very close with the Trump
campaign he repeatedly defended Gucci
42.0 he seems to be working with gusta
for a 2.0 but that doesn't mean he
necessarily knew the Gousha for 2.0 was
actually the Russians or that he was
talking specifically with President
Trump about directly interacting with
42.0 goose 42.0 was also working with
wikileaks according to the indictment
the conspirators also used the gusta
42.0 persona to release additional
stolen documents through a website
maintained by an organization that had
previously posted documents stolen from
u.s. persons entities and the US
government presumably that would be
WikiLeaks they released over 20,000
emails and other documents stolen from
the DNC Network that began three days
before the DNC as I recall President
Trump has been saying all along he
doesn't think that the hacking was
actually the Russians he thought that
was a 400-pound man living in his
mother's basement or some such nonsense
and then there are a bunch of conspiracy
theorists including some pretty
mainstream voices who suggested that it
was all set
there was some DNC staffer who had
actually leaked all of these emails to
gusoff ur 2.0 who had released all of
them and then they suggested that set
which was murdered over that there was
no evidence for any of that and it
turned out to be false right all of this
turned out to be false well here is the
problem here's what the left perceives
and then here's what the right perceives
and I think that there are some elements
of truth to the perceptions of both but
the truth lies somewhere between so the
left perceives is that President Trump
was very pro-russian since the beginning
of the campaign this must have been
because he was in Vladimir Putin's
pocket and then when the Russians
started hacking it was pretty clear and
it must have been that Trump was
coordinating with Russia to make all
that happen because that's the only way
Hillary Clinton possibly could have lost
this election is if Donald Trump and the
Russians conspired to steal the election
and then they say well now Trump is
being super pro-russian and super anti
probe because he knows the probe is
going to find something and because he
believes that the Russians were the
people who got him elected and he's best
friends with them okay so here's what
they're right about and here's what
they're wrong about they are right that
the Russians attempted to affect the
election in 2016 they're correct about
this they are wrong about everything
else at least so far as the evidence
says now there is no actual hard
evidence that the Trump administration
from campaign coordinated with the
Russians during the campaign or post
campaign in order to create soft Russian
policy there's no evidence of that at
all and there's no evidence that Trump
is personally important pocket now
here's what the write says what the
write says is Donald Trump is not in
Putin's pocket and Donald Trump did not
cheat during the election Hillary
Clinton just lost it hey Donald Trump
has not been too weak on Russia he's
actually pretty harsh on Russia in terms
of policy and that and therefore all of
this hacking talk and all of the
collusion
nonsense all of the hacking and all the
collusion talk is nonsense all that is
gins up by people who just don't like
Trump now that is also only half true
it's true that Trump is not in Putin's
pocket it is true as far as we know that
Trump did not coordinate with the
Russians during the campaign but it is
not true that the Russians did not
attempt to it is not true that the
Russians didn't hack into the DCCC or
the DNC or Hillary Clinton's campaign so
I'm gonna tell you the real story in
just a second and then we'll see how
these two narratives play into what the
right and the left are saying about the
Trump Putin summit first I want to say
thanks to our sponsors over at
betterment so betterment is the largest
online financial advisor their designs
help customers build wealth plan for
retirement achieve their financial goals
here's the reality you think about
spending time playing the stock market
or investing in real estate how much
time you actually gonna spend on there
the answer is probably not a lot you're
just gonna stick that money in the bank
and it's gonna sit there earning an
extraordinarily low rate of interest
well this is why you need to talk to the
folks over at betterment because these
are the financial advisors that you need
at betterment hidden costs are nowhere
to be found they charge these really low
fees no matter who you are how much
money you invest you get everything from
one low transparent management fee and
they are fiduciary which means they make
recommendations and clients best
interest they're not incentivized to
recommend certain funds they don't have
our own investment products to sell
right betterment offers personalized
advice a tool of suite of tools to help
you know whether you're on track to hit
your investing goals or get the
retirement that you want and when you
need it they're tools and guidance can
help you get on track I have a financial
advisor you should too
the folks over at betterment really know
what they're doing listen investing
always involves risk but these are some
of the people who can help mitigate that
risk and manage that risk Ben Shapiro
show listeners can get up to one year
manage for free for more information go
to betterment comm slash Shapiro that's
B et te RM ent comm slash appear oh
that's betterment comm slash Shapiro is
an online financial advisor that will
help you manage your money better
mint.com slash pro reach those
retirement goals and then you don't have
to do it yourself betterment comm slash
/ you can get up to one year managed for
free it's a fantastic service you really
owe it to yourself to go check it out ok
so how do these two narratives
play into what everybody is saying about
the Trump Russia the Trump Putin sort of
sort of meeting okay so first of all
let's talk about what Trump is saying
about the collusion investigation so
here's what Trump tweeted so Trump
tweeted out these
individuals did their worth during the
Obama years why didn't Obama do
something about this because he thought
crooked Hillary would win
that's why had nothing to do with the
Trump administration but fake news
doesn't want to report the truth as
usual okay so he's not wrong that Obama
didn't do enough about it obviously but
Trump would go on to essentially claim
that a lot of this was just false in
general that the hacking itself may have
happened or didn't happen or has been or
has been exaggerated in some way right
he's focusing in on that angle and
that's what he's been that's what he's
been saying sort of all along he he
didn't actually he hasn't yet said that
the indictments themselves were BS but
they're allies of his who have said that
the indictments themselves are being so
Devin Nunez over at the House
Intelligence Committee right he says
that this is basically a witch hunt the
indictment in itself is ridiculous this
is a clip three the indictment plays
like they're only going after the
Democrats when Bob Muller and all his
investigators and his lawyers know for a
fact that they also targeted Republicans
why is that not in the indictment
it makes the indictment look ridiculous
okay all of that is fine but the fact is
the indictment says what the indictment
says and it's pretty clear the Russians
were trying to meddle in the election
again because the right is trying to
claim that Trump is not in the pocket of
Putin which he isn't they're also trying
to claim that the entire indictment is
wrong that somehow the Russians were not
attempting to affect the election in a
serious way and it's because Republicans
are reacting like this it's because
Trump has reacted like this that the
left therefore thinks that Trump is even
more in the pocket of Putin right so
here's how it goes the left says Trump
is in Putin's pocket and he's in Putin's
pocket because Putin hacks the election
and Trump says wait a second I'm not in
Putin's pocket and also Putin didn't
hack the election and lets us see he's
lying about Putin hacking the election
which shows that he's in Putin's pocket
in terms but wait I'm not in Putin's
pocket and you're the ones who are
claiming he hacked the election so why
am I supposed to believe you and so you
see how this goes around and around in a
circle now the real answer is Putin did
attempt to affect the election and
Donald Trump is not in Putin's pocket
right both of these things can be true
all at once and the problem is then
nobody is going to play this honestly
nobody is going to honestly look at
these issues and look where the evidence
takes them instead they're going to jump
to the assumption they think most meets
with with their preconception of the
situation itself now
all of this was exacerbated by the
run-up to the Russian meeting so in the
run-up to the Russian meeting President
Trump started signaling that he was anti
EU he'd spent the NATO meetings talking
about the shortcomings in NATO and a lot
of people were saying well this is
signaling weakness to Vladimir Putin
first I do have to note that if there's
a group of people who can make President
Trump look wonderful it is his protestor
so this is a group of protesters
apparently over the weekend who decided
to take on president Trump I guess this
was in London or San Francisco yeah
there's that there's a dummy of
President Trump and it looks like a
bunch of gay activists who are punching
the dummy of President Trump and losing
yeah this is very inspiring stuff deeply
inspiring this guy's got the the right
hook of my grandmother and she's 88 in
the hospital so it's a really solid
group of folks yes this is clearly
making the discourse just enormous Lee
enormous Lee better just really really
well done over there okay so anyway
president Trump is over in Europe and in
the middle of his visit to Britain he
suggests that the EU is a foe on trade
here's what he has to say I think we
have a lot of foes I think the European
Union is a foe what they do to us in
trade now you wouldn't think of the
European Union but they're a foe but
that doesn't mean they're bad it doesn't
mean anything it means that they're
competitors they want to do well and we
want to do well so again it's president
Trump's language people are paying
attention to where he says that they're
a foe what people are saying is that
well he's saying that Russia's a foe and
the EU zippo the EU Xin Li Russia is not
an ally but the truth is the president
Trump uses words like foe pretty loosely
he uses words like friend pretty loosely
the president is very loose with his
language none of this means that the
policy that emerges is going to be
dramatically anti-eu and dramatically
pro-russian and you know president Trump
I think had the most accurate take on
this this meeting in Helsinki frankly he
didn't expect much to happen at all
here's what he had to say I don't expect
anything I frankly don't expect I go
with very low expectations I think that
getting along with Russia is a good
thing okay so he goes in with low
expectations and getting along with
Russia is a good thing and nothing came
out of it right so all we know today is
that nothing really came out of these
meetings president Trump's had a lot of
words a lot of people are angered by
those words that is you know the I think
it's it's it is fine to be angry at
stuff that President Trump says in the
same way that was fine to be angry what
Obama said the difference is the Trump
says stuff and it doesn't mean a lot
very often when President Obama said
things that were anti-american it
usually manifested his policy when Obama
went around the world and did his
apology tour that manifested in military
cuts an attempt to reduce America's
influence around the world when
President Trump goes around and says
were all the blame for 2016 when he goes
around he says well when it comes to
Russia American relations we all carry a
little bit of blame when he says that
kind of stuff is it gross is it
off-putting yes does it manifest his
policy not really remember this is the
same guy who said twice in the last
three years that the United States kills
people in the same way that Russia kills
people has that manifested in anything
like a soft policy with regard to Russia
and the answer of course is no and it's
this massive disconnect people are
having a real problem with their Trump
says things that are very egregious
often and when it comes to actual policy
the policy is pretty good and this has
been true pretty much across the board
in many many many ways this has been
true right the President of the United
States has a lot of stuff and nothing
much comes out so here is what President
Trump tweeted out about the upcoming
Russian meeting so he tweeted a bunch of
stuff he tweeted the stories you heard
about the 12 Russians yesterday took
place during the Obama administration
not the Trump administration why didn't
they do something about it especially
when it was reported President Obama was
informed by the FBI in September before
the election okay then he continued
along these lines and he said
congratulations to friends who played
extraordinary soccer and winning the
2018 World Cup
additionally congratulations to
President Putin and Russia for putting
on a truly great World Cup tournament
one of the best ever and people went
nuts over this because oh my god he's
complimenting Putin as opposed to Obama
who also would have complimented Putin
on the handling of the World Cup Hillary
Clinton by the way tweeted in response
to this Hillary tweeted in response
great World Cup question for president
Trump as he meets Putin do you know
which team you play for well Hillary he
doesn't play soccer I'm like you he's
the president so there's that but he
says great world which team does he play
for this is the left misperception that
Trump plays for Team Russia no Trump
says a lot of sense here is Trump's
general approach to negotiations Trump's
general approach to negotiations is he
tries to win you over he tries to be
really nice to you he tries to be really
suave and debonair and charming he tries
to charm you into a position where you
like him and then he hopes to get
something out of you
okay that doesn't actually manifest in
terms of him giving something over very
often this is this is what people are
just going to have to deal with the fact
that Trump says a lot of crap he says a
lot of stuff that I don't like and that
I find morally off-putting about when it
comes to policy it doesn't manifest all
that often in policy and you can tell
that from the actual policy but his
sweets are but we do have to note when
his tweets are bad so here are the rest
of his sweets the president continued he
said heading to Helsinki Finland
looking forward to meeting with
President Putin tomorrow unfortunately
no matter how well I do at summit if I
was given the great city of Moscow as
retribution for all of the sins and
evils committed by Russia over the years
I would return to criticism that it
wasn't good enough that I should have
gotten st. Petersburg in addition much
of our news media is indeed the enemy of
the paper and all the Dems know how to
do is resist and obstruct this is why
there is such hatred and dissension in
our country but at some point it will
heal so again it's all about president
Trump is one of the operating things
about the president is that everything
seems to be about president Trump except
for policy now here's the reaction to
all of us so the reaction to all of this
begins with some folks on the right who
are very upset with President Trump and
it extends to some people on the Left
who are very upset with President Trump
again I think there's a lot of sound and
fury signifying nothing in the end first
I want to say thanks to our sponsors
over at Mint mobile so you probably have
a deal with some big wireless company
and you're probably spending a fortune
on your wireless coverage every month
there is no reason for you to do that
the big and big Wireless stands for a
lot of things big contracts big bills
big secrets companies like AT&T and
Verizon they don't want you to know that
there's a way to cut your wireless bill
down to just 15 bucks a month this is
mint mobile the game-changing company
they've taken everything wrong with big
Wireless they've made it right mint
mobile is proving to millions of
Americans getting your wireless bill
doesn't have to be the worst day of the
month mint Mobile makes it supremely
easy to cut your wireless bill down to
just 15 bucks a month you use your own
phone with any mint mobile plan you can
keep your old number along with all of
your existing contacts and then you can
choose 18 to 5 or 10 gigabyte 4G LTE
plans no more paying for unlimited data
that you will never use and because
you're not paying for unlimited data
they are never going to use you get a
much much cheaper price by the way the
coverage is just the same as it would be
with one of these major carriers because
my understanding is that they work with
one of these major carriers to ensure
the coverage every plan comes with
unlimited talk in text so you can safely
annoy your friends and loved ones and if
you're not 100% satisfied mint mobile
has you covered with their
day money-back guarantee so you can try
it see if it works out for you outfox
that old wireless bill start saving with
mint mobile to get your new mint
wireless plan for just 15 bucks a month
plus free shipping on your mint Mobile
SIM card go to mint mobile comm slash
Ben that's em int mo bi le comm slash
man mint mobile comm slash Ben and cut
that Wireless bill to 15 bucks a month
save yourself hundreds of ucks a year
get free shipping on your mint Mobile
SIM card mint mobile comm slash Ben go
check it out right now it really is a
fantastic way to save money okay so
people don't actually understand that
what President Trump says what he does
are two very very different things and
so people are responding and I think
right we outrage fashion over president
Trump's language because no presidents
in the United States should be saying
the kind of things about America in
relation to Russia that the presidents
of the United States has been saying and
I understand there are a lot of Trump
fans who say well really what he means
is that Barack Obama's policy with
Russia was bad or really what he means
was george w bush's policy with russia
was bad the reality is no matter how bad
American policy has been and it usually
has been bad in terms of weakness not in
terms of strength the only way that you
are going to be able to confront
Vladimir Putin is by confronting
Vladimir Putin it's not gonna be done
with kissing his ass it's certainly not
gonna be done by blaming America for
Putin America anger or dissension
because the reality is that Putin's been
doing this since he got into office but
apparently President Trump said that
we've had a bad relationship with Russia
but that all changed about four hours
ago when he got in a room with him I
mean this is the same thing the
president Trump said about Kim Jong Liu
remember this he went over met with kim
jeong-hoon someone from critical of that
meeting saying that meeting was
counterproductive and useless and that
in fact it was elevating kim jong hoon
on the world stage and then President
Trump came back and he tweeted out that
we no longer had to worry about in
nuclear in North Korea which of course
was very very silly but did America's
policy and North Korea change in any
massive way not really and the same
thing is happening with regard to Russia
this is why john huntsman who is the US
ambassador to russia he says listen it's
highly unlikely the Trump is gonna
recognize annexation of Crimea or
something you can't rule out the
possibility he might recognize Russia's
annexation of Crimea highly unlikely
Hermia was a violation of international
law we all recognize that that's us
policy okay so none of this is none of
this is going to manifest in terms of
policy again Trump keeps saying these
things and they're they're really really
dumb and they're really really
ridiculous but I'm not sure I'm really
not sure that it has any real
ramifications again I don't think that's
me grasping at straws here I think that
there is a massive disconnect between
the stuff Trump says and the stuff that
Trump does in his office I think that
the President of the United States has
so many things by the way he just
President Putin presented President
Trump with a soccer ball from the World
Cup so that's really exciting I'm sure
that and and then and then Putin said to
Trump the ball is in your court
seriously it's just yuck yuck
apparently Trump criticized the focus on
his campaign and Putin apparently
apparently ripped on the on the
indictments themselves and again none of
this is good all of this is really bad
all of this is really bad he says Putin
said as for who to believe who you can't
believe can you believe it all you can't
believe anyone so that's that's really
that's really great all of this is just
spectacular so again you know I keep
saying it over and over because I don't
think anything is changing here Trump
says a lot of crap there's only two ways
to read this either what Trump says
matters or what he says does not matter
if what he says matters he said a lot of
bad stuff today if what he says does not
matter then who cares what he says and I
think in reality it doesn't matter a
whole lot I really don't think that John
Bolton I think the people who actually
implement policy ignore President Trump
a lot of the time yeah I'm not somebody
who believes that having been to the
White House I do not believe that
President Trump is sitting there playing
40 chess upstairs micromanaging the
workings of the cybersecurity profile
under the DHS I really don't think
that's what's happening here but you
know we'll have to see how it plays out
in terms of policy it's just the
president should not be saying these
types of things they should okay so
meanwhile meanwhile the Democrats are
gearing up for 2020 and they are very
very much in love with a particular set
of candidates Joe Biden apparently wants
to make a comeback at age 83 he's
actually I gonna be 78 I guess in 2020
and he says that President Trump's
immigration policies make him ashamed
about these poor kids on the border in
can I just ask you that how does that
make you feel if you if you and your
administrator shame ashamed hmm you feel
ashamed I really mean it I mean it's and
and I'm proud of the response American
people Democrat and Republican this is
not America it's not who we are okay so
this is this is gonna be Biden's routine
it's not gonna be our routine is gonna
come back with a vengeance and the
reality of course is that a lot of these
policies were implemented under
President Obama in the first place but
the favorite of the left is not in fact
Joe Biden the favor of the left is
Anastacio Ocasio Cortes I got her name
right this time I always screw it up and
I'm not sure why that is it's just a
very long name so she was on with with
Margaret Hoover of Stanford University
and Margaret Hoover was asking her on
firing line about her beliefs about the
Middle East now let it be known on
Estancia Ocasio cortez she's a 28 year
old former bartender she has her degree
in international relations so watch it
she begs off the question because she
doesn't know where Israel is doesn't
know where the Palestinians are and
thinks that screaming occupation into
the air means something watch it it's
amazing what people are starting to see
at least in the occupation of Palestine
is just an increasing crisis of
humanitarian condition you use the term
the occupation of Palestine mm-hmm what
did you mean by that
oh I think it what I meant is like the
the settlements that are increasing and
in some of these areas and places where
or Palestinians are experiencing
difficulty and access to their housing
and homes do you think you can expand on
that
yeah I mean I think I'd also just I I am
NOT the expert on geopolitics on this
issue you literally has an international
relations degree so let's be clear about
something
if anastasi Ocasio cortez were a
republican is there any doubt that she
would be labeled crazy eyes nuts doesn't
know what she's talking about
stupid affirmative action candidate
right is exactly judge Michelle Bachman
and Sarah Palin you remember it they
said it over and over and over about
every Republican woman who was ever in a
position of power it was that she was
stupid she was affirmative action she
was only there because she was pretty
right they did that again
to this about every Republican woman who
ever reached a position of power that I
can remember except for maybe
Condoleezza Rice and they couldn't say
it about her because she was black and
they didn't want to say it about a black
woman but there is no question that this
woman is a dunderhead
it does show where the base of the
Democratic Party is though if she says
occupation over and over and over and
doesn't know what the occupation is
doesn't know what she's talking about
has no clue and then begs off the
question and gets away with it it shows
you that the base of the Democratic
Party is anti-israel it also shows how
radical the base of the Democratic Party
is pretty astonishing stuff so Anastacio
Ocasio cortez who has been named by Tom
Perez the future of the Democratic Party
demonstrating full scale and why she is
the future of the Democratic Party she's
ignorant she knows nothing but she will
be considered genius no matter what
because she's a Democratic Socialist
just incredible stuff they're from the
Democrats okay in just a second don't
get too Sacha Baron Cohen who's making
headlines anew with his new series but
first we're gonna have to go over to
Daley we're calm and subscribed so for
$9.99 a month you can subscribe to daily
wire comm when you do you get the rest
of my show live you get the rest of me
Andrew Clavin show live the rest of
Michael Mosley's show live also you've
probably heard by now I'm taking the Ben
Shapiro show live this August to
audiences in Dallas in Phoenix you
should know we have now sold out of our
general admission tickets for Dallas
we're opening up the very last 800 seats
available we're almost sold out of our
events in Phoenix if you haven't gotten
your tickets yet you should get them now
or else you could miss out on the event
entirely so go over to Daley wired.com
slash events to ensure that you've got
all of that also reminder YouTube has
manipulated the subscription feeds to
curate your choices it means that users
may not be notified if our channel goes
live even if you subscribe to the
channel already in order to make sure
you receive notifications for our live
videos you should not only subscribe to
daily wire on YouTube but also ring that
little bell so you know when we post new
content when you subscribe by the way
get the annual subscription not the
$9.99 a month when you want the better
one you want the $99 a year one which
brings you this they left his tears hot
or cold tumblr the very greatest and all
beverage vessels go check it out right
now and you will not be disappointed we
are the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]
okay so the future of the Democratic
Party is a Nastasia Ocasio Cortez who
doesn't know the hell she's talking
about on virtually any topic that's very
exciting Joe Biden wants to run
attitudes basically dead so that's
pretty exciting as well the other
candidates who are being talked about
are people like Kirsten Gillibrand
Elizabeth Warren and Cory Booker none of
whom are deeply inspiring I would say at
this point the front-runner would
probably have to be Biden if Obama
endorses him if Ho Bhama does not
endorse him then the front-runner is
likely somebody like Elizabeth Warren
who is deemed to be sort of the Bernie
Sanders double except she's female and
empowered and so that's that's very
selfish as Native American background as
we keep hearing meanwhile from the
meanwhile folks in the media are very
very excited because Sacha Baron Cohen
is back now Sacha Baron Cohen can be
really really funny if you ever watched
any of the Ali G show it's extremely
extremely funny well now he has a brand
new show and this show is basically
punking Americans right the show is
called who is America on Showtime and
it's essentially him going to a series
of Americans mostly on the right wing
and trying to make them look foolish
it's sort of like he did in Borat where
he went down south and then you know
walked into churches where people were
speaking in tongues he made them look
stupid and then did that routine where
he went into a bar and started thinking
singing throw the Jew down the well
because obviously everybody in the bar
was an anti-semite and this is the stuff
that Sacha Baron Cohen does well this
time he posed as an Israeli former
Mossad agent who wanted to start a
program program in the United States
arming four-year-olds and he got a bunch
of Republican Congressmen to talk about
how wonderful this idea would be he
couldn't get Matt Gaetz right Matt Gaetz
was smart enough to avoid it but there
were a few other Republicans who got who
got sucked into it typically members of
Congress don't just hear a story about a
program and then indicate whether they
support it or not the intensive three
week kindergarten course introduces
specially selected children from 12 to 4
years old to pistols rifles
semi-automatics and a rudimentary
knowledge of mortars in less than a
month less than a month a first grader
can become a first Grenadier okay so all
of this is a little bit inherently funny
getting all of these Republicans on
record saying they want to teach young
children how to use grenades right all
of this a little is inherently funny but
I will point
out that it is actually extraordinarily
easy to do this it's very very easy to
get people to say stupid things when
they say when they believe they're
saying something that they're not saying
so here was Joe Walsh's explanation he's
former Illinois Congress person and he
was on Sarah Palin he was with Sarah
Palin and Roy Moore stuck in this who in
America who who is America series and
here's what Walsh said he said Cohn is a
funny guy because he gets people to say
stupid thing he gets people to say
stupid things because he lies to them so
here's what Walsh says so Walsh explains
that he was invited by Cohen to go on
some Israeli TV station to get an award
he says after they conducted an
interview they had me read off a
teleprompter talking about some of the
innovative products that Israel invented
then they had me read about this
four-year-old child in Israel who when a
terrorist entered his classroom somehow
he grabbed the terrorists gun in hell
the terrorists at bay and that was an
example of how Israel trains and arms
preschool kids on how to use firearms
and boys shouldn't we do that in America
he said as he read it he thought well
this is kind of crazy but it is Israel
and Israel is strong on defense they
said later we found out this whole thing
was made up he say didn't realize until
three on the next day he'd been duped he
reiterated on Twitter Sunday that he
didn't believe that we should train and
arm kindergarteners and then he urged
people to boycott Showtime and he says
that they gave him a fake award and he
shows what the what the award says and
it says Shivam least even seventy at
seventy four significant contributions
to the State of Israel so basically it
was they got him in a mood
to believe that he was with friends and
then they told him what to say off a
teleprompter and they did this with a
series of people now before you think
well he's an idiot he shouldn't have
fallen for that understand that you
would have fallen for the same thing in
all likelihood the chance is that you
would not fall for that sort of prank
are extraordinarily low and that doesn't
mean that Sacha Baron Cohen did did
anything deeply wrong in in pranking
people like this he did something deeply
wrong if he posed as a wounded soldier
with Sarah Palin I'm not sure that he
did something deeply wrong posing as an
Israeli Mossad agent to trick joe walsh
but it does demonstrate that you you
want to know why it is really you wanna
know why it is that so many folks on the
right our deeply skeptical of the media
and don't actually want to have open
interviews with people in the media
because they feel like this every time
they sit down with them it's a trap
every time you sit down with somebody
who's an unfriendly it's a trap there's
a reason that President Trump announced
that he would be giving his first
interviews after all of this was over to
Tucker Carlson and Sean Hannity he wants
to sit down with friendlies and the
reason for that is you really do have to
vet the people you sit down
and if you don't trust them you don't
sit down with them in the first place
because otherwise you may very well end
up in a situation just like Sasha Baron
Cohen's now is it good for the country
that Sasha Baron Cohen is doing all of
this I'm not sure that it is just in the
sense that do you really think that all
of these Republicans are actually gonna
vote for that sort of a bill what's the
point of this if the point of this is to
say they can trick Republican Congress
people into saying dumb things I mean I
don't think you need a trick to make
Republican Congress people say dumb
things they do it on a fairly regular
basis but if the idea here is that
Republicans actually support this sort
of stuff then what they are actually
going for here is arming four-year-olds
but that's really where their heart lies
then I think that it's it's all it
contributes to is the cynicism about
politics that is unwarranted I do not
think many politicians on the right are
walking around actively promoting the
idea of four-year-olds with guns any
more than I really think that there are
a lot of politicians on the Left who are
actively promoting the idea that we're
going to take children away from their
parents if you don't teach them about
transgenderism and I think we're a lot
closer to the second than we are to the
first I think that there are a lot of
people in the California State
Legislature who believe that you should
be able to teach children what you want
from the state schools and if you don't
teach those kids what you want from the
state schools then they are going to
move toward somehow cracking down on
parents but they will say that without
having to be prompted right the real
question is what do people say without
having to be prompted what do people say
in public without having to be prompted
so I think most Democrats have in their
mind I want to see these children from
their parents I don't think that and I
don't think most Republicans have on
their mind they want to separate kids
from parents at the borders I don't
think most Republicans have on their
minds that they want to arm
four-year-old children I really don't
think that the gap in the country is
that wide but again if the goal is just
to make people look stupid then I guess
that people can look stupid and we're
all supposed to pretend that that all of
this is normal it's there the reality is
our system was built for a lot of
interplay our system was built to weed
out stupid ideas our system was built by
people who are proposing their own
legislation not being duped into
proposing legislation by people like
Sasha Baron Cohen and so the left Glee
about this that really what gun owners
wanted to arm four-year-olds is really I
think over overwrought in a pretty
significant way so when people say this
is America no this isn't America there's
a guy pranking America
okay and legitimately you can do this
with pretty much anyone it's really not
all that hard okay in just a second I
want to explain
one of the ways in which some false
research has now become part of the
American lexicon so here that there's a
I'm sure you've seen all these headlines
they're a bunch of headlines that have
now come out that have been coming out
for years and years and years and years
they basically suggest that Republicans
conservatives are more authoritarian
usually what the study suggests is that
if you have a tendency toward believing
in rules then you are going to be more
authoritarian by nature if you have a
tendency toward believing in in certain
hard standards that's because you're an
author Arian and therefore you are going
to become a conservative and there have
been studies and and headlines about
this for the last several years as
particularly exacerbated as President
Trump became president from a lot of
people say well this is the
authoritarian nature of the right and
finally the authoritarians on the right
are showing their true colors now really
all of this goes back to the so-called
Frankfurt School the Frankfurt School a
group of German expatriates who came
over prior to World War two in the
remarks istake aim to the United States
and one of the things that they promoted
was the idea that America was a
right-wing capitalist country on the
verge of authoritarianism they were
trying to suggest that Nazism was an
outgrowth of a capitalist free system
because capitalism and freedom were an
outgrowth of actually a hierarchical
system that implanted in people a desire
to believe in authority erich fromm was
one of the leaders here a famous
psychologist he argued that fascism
would rise in the United States thanks
to its devotion to capitalism
he said capitalism sprang from social
structures that had urged compulsive
conformity in the process of which the
isolated individual becomes an automaton
once the idea is that you are just a
you're a Babbitt you're a you're a loser
who goes to work and you slavishly
follow the rules because you are
actually an authoritarian and that's why
capitalism works in the United States he
says that we all have authoritarianism
is these online surveys where they ask
you questions about do you believe that
flag-burning should be banned and they
say if you believe that flag-burning
should be banned it's because you're an
authoritarian they say people on the
right their authoritarianism entity's
rigid right-wing mindsets and people on
the left they're just more free brain
you know they're just more liberal and
open and they just like things more it
turns out all of this is nonsense jesse
single over at new york magazine who is
on the left
but does some really good social science
work he says these scales in short are
all too often structured in a way in
which respondents tendencies toward
dogmatism
mindedness or intolerance are
ascertained by asking them about issues
that are politicized and while social
and political psychologists have
sometimes asked about rigidity in ways
designs tap liberal ideas the FAMAS
authoritarianism researcher bob
altameyer for example did publish a
left-wing authoritarianism scale this
has been the exception rather than the
norm in other words we've been told for
years and years and years that
right-wing czar right-wingers are
authoritarians and it turns out that
that's not true it depends on how you do
the test so when you encounter an
authoritarian quiz online it usually is
about banning flag-burning but you'll
never see an authoritarian quiz online
talking about banning hate speech why
because the people who are designing
those quizzes want the results to come
out that right-wingers are more
authoritarian as it turns out there are
people who have come up with tests that
are biased against the left and here's
what it found these tweaks affected
which group responded more dogmatically
a great deal liberals scored as more
dogmatic than conservatives when it came
to their agreement with sentiments like
when it comes to stopping global warming
it is better to be a dead hero than a
live coward and a person who thinks
primarily of his or her own happiness
and in doing so disrespects the health
of the environment is beneath contempt
while conservatives by contrast scored
higher than liberals on items tuned in
the opposite political direction so
again speaking of the Sacha Baron Cohen
technique with regard of the media it
also applies to science very often some
of the social science that you read is
inherently biased in an attempt to
generate a headline it's one of the
reasons why we always have to be very
careful when we read social science
headlines and determine whether or not
they are true this is why there are some
of us who are very critical of a lot of
the social science with regard to for
example transgenderism because it seems
like a lot of this stuff is biased in
its construction it seems like the media
is attempting to push an agenda mainly
because the media are attempting to push
an agenda there's a headline from the
New York Times about a transgender
competitor in from Spain in the Miss
Universe contest and the headline was
basically isn't it wonderful that this
transgender competitor is teaching
schoolchildren that girls can have a
penis and boys can have a vagina and the
answer is no that's not wonderful
because that's anti scientific but when
you bias the science when you make up
the science as you go it turns out that
it's very easy to generate a headline in
any direction that you wish to generate
a headline and this is just the latest
example the most obvious examples so
next time before you believe a social
science headline check out the basis of
the headline it may very well be that
the people who designed it were
looking for a particular outcome before
they even began okay time for some
things I like things I hate then we'll
do a Federalist paper so today's thing
things I like so
Alexandria Ocasio Cortes getting it
right for the first time today
Alexandria okay not on the stage yeah
Alexandria Oh Kazuya Cortez our great
heroine she says she is a democratic
socialist Democratic Socialist typically
say they are not socialists she is she
actually wants to nationalize stuff but
democratic social say we're not
socialists we like the free-market
system we just want to redistribute all
the gains right we want private
ownership of things but we want to
redistribute when you know like Denmark
or Norway or any of those other
countries like the Netherlands there's
only one problem with this all of this
worship of Denmark Norway the
Netherlands neglects what exactly made
Denmark Norway in the Netherlands
economic powerhouses before they
attempted socialist projects it also
neglects the fact that in the past
several years they've had to cut social
silence Social Services specifically
because of all of the massive growth of
governments and the incentive systems
that have been created that are allowing
people not to work a great book on this
topic is a book called debunking utopia
by Nima san anton ji who was a
middle-eastern immigrant to norway and
it's debunking utopia exposing the myth
of Nordic socialism it's about 250 pages
something like that and it is and it is
a very clean debunking of the idea that
this is utopia and they can just
translate it over to the United States
it's got all the stats and figures that
you'd want and make some pretty good
points about how it is that people bias
the case in favor of Norway or Denmark
and against the United States when in
reality Denmark particularly is a
capitalist system and they're
redistribute and they're
redistributionist programs have have
actually dampened the growth and a
pretty significant way over there also
he explains why it is that you can't
just take their system apply it to the
United States and hope that it works the
same way because it obviously does not
even the biggest point I think of the
book is that when you look at a lot of
these democratic socialist utopia these
places were basically great places to
live before democratic socialism because
the culture in Norway and the culture
and Denmark
it's a homogeneous culture where people
pretty much act alike and are part of a
common family at least part of a common
bond and that common bond is not nearly
as ethnically diverse and culturally
diverse as the United States you can't
just take those programs apply them into
the United States and if soom they're
going to impact in the same way
makes a great point which is that if you
look at Danish expatriates to the United
States make sure you earn more than then
Danes back at home so it's pretty it's
pretty good book two bunking utopia
check it out Nemo salmon dodgy exposing
the myth of Nordic socialism okay
time for a quick thing that I hate so
speaking of trying to import Nordic
socialism to the United States an
Francisco's been trying this for years
and it is giant fail they've been trying
this with rent control they've been
trying this with all sorts of benefits
for the homeless they've been trying
this with the idea that you have a right
to sleep on the streets and the result
has been giant piles of poop in the
street so here's the mayor of San
Francisco explaining that what used to
be one of the cleanest cities in America
now has piles of feces on the corner
you're a native of San Francisco is this
the worst you've seen that I will say
that there is more there's more feces on
the sidewalks and I've ever seen you
know growing up here that was something
that did not wasn't the norm that you've
ever seen
then I've ever seen for sure and that is
a huge problem and we're not just
talking about from from dogs we're
talking about from humans okay so that's
just delightful and then there's a
picture of poo so glad we can all
experience that NBC Bay Area but you can
experience that every day in San
Francisco
thanks to leftist governance so well
done there over in San Francisco hey
other things that I hate okay so the New
York Times says that homophobia is bad
because homophobia is bad right you
shouldn't just like assume that cuz
someone's gay they've done something
terribly wrong in terms of their
lifestyle right you shouldn't just
assume that homosexual people are bad
and you shouldn't use gay as a slur
right if you're a kid on a playground
you certainly shouldn't look in another
can say hey you're gay and you what you
mean is something bad by it you should
never do something like that unless they
didn't you're the New York Times making
fun of Trump and Putin so they actually
release this video over at the New York
Times and it is pretty astonishing they
thought this was okay but they did do
you have a relationship with Vladimir
Putin
it's a picture relationship Trump
opening the door
muscular Vladimir Putin Trump feeling
his heart beating giving him his heart
and there is Vladimir Putin riding the
car Trump putting his hand on Vladimir
Putin's hand his tiny have letter in
Putin's huge hand and then them riding a
unicorn both of them nearly naked
riding through a field of rainbows is
seriously the New York Times put this
out and then them looking into each
other's eyes with love and then Trump
kissing Vladimir Putin and fireblaze in
between their lips as they actually play
tongue hockey with each other it's
really disgusting okay and so that's
that's the New York Times to take on
this so homophobia totally fine as long
as it's about Donald Trump amazing you
remember when when Stephen Colbert did
the same thing right he said that Donald
Trump was being used by Vladimir Putin
as his bleep holster meaning his genital
holster and that was totally fine so you
can make you can make jokes about gays
and about homosexuality so long as
you're doing it about Republicans that's
the way this work so well done left
you're just you're not hypocritical in
any way okay finally a federalist paper
so our politics has become rather
degraded and silly you may have noticed
this well let's go back to the founders
who are not quite as degraded and silly
James Madison Federalist 37 he talks
about why it is that we need a
constitution he says the purpose of the
Constitution is to balance energy and
stability he says energy and government
is essential to that security against
external and internal danger and so that
prompt and salutary execution of the
laws which enter into the very
definition of good government stability
and government is essential to national
character and so the advantages annexed
to it as well as to that repose and
confidence in the minds of the people
returning the chief blessings of civil
society so you need energy but also
stability so how do you create a
government that both can respond
energetically to foreign crises and
domestic crises but is also stable and
that's what the Constitution is for he
says listen in trying to balance those
things it's kind of a miracle we've
gotten this far he says the real wonder
is that so many difficulties should have
been surmounted and surmounted with the
unanimity almost as unprecedented as it
must have been unexpected it is
impossible for any man of candor to
reflect on this circumstance without
partaking of the astonishment and this
is exactly right when you have a group
of people who are put together on earth
by the Almighty at a certain points in
time to create a system that was durable
enough to withstand Barack Obama and
Donald Trump right a system durable
enough to withstand the Democrats and
the Republicans of today you have to
admire that system in a pretty major way
and it was a system that was created by
compromising a system that's created by
gridlock and a system that was designed
to check the worst impulses of people so
our mind folks Donald Trump's had a lot
of bad things today in that press
conference with press conference with
Vladimir Putin the fact of the matter
that this is a very durable form of
government and well everybody is should
be concerned about that sort of language
when it comes to actual foreign policy
the United States has done pretty well
over the past couple of centuries and I
don't think one press conference is
gonna change that okay
we'll be back here tomorrow with all the
latest I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover
and our technical producer is Austin
Stevens edited by Alex and Garo audio is
mixed by Mike Carmina hair and makeup is
by Jess wah
of era the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire for word publishing production
copyright Ford publishing 2018